d'une dictature l'autre la roumanie
maintenant c'est le mauvais exemple des
démocraties populaires tout change pas
elle il y à quelques minutes le
dictateur ceausescu le danube de la
pensée comme il se fait appeler a
reconnu que l'armée était bien intervenu
à timisoara mais pour lui ce n'était que
des hooligans ce qui avait semé la
violence
en fait la répression face aux
manifestants a été d'une violence inouïe
hier on parlait de 300 à 400 morts selon
certaines sources fournies aujourd'hui
par l' agence de presse adn le bilan
serait plutôt de 3000 ou 4000 morts et
ce soir on a appris que deux nouvelles
manifestations avaient lieu à timisoara
cinquante mille personnes selon
certaines sources manifesterait jérôme
boni dernier témoignage d'abord décrit à
bâche à eau chez scoop puis à l'adresse
des soldats qui s'approche on avoue
cochons ils viennent vers nous clame
quelqu'un éclate alors les premiers
coups de feu
la fusille elle s'amplifie mitrailleuses
lourdes et enfin les chars sur ce
document sonore l'ampleur de la
répression contre les manifestants de
timisoara le 17 décembre
ce soir à la télévision roumaine nicolas
ceausescu l'a d'ailleurs reconnu les
unités militaires ont été obligés de
défendre l'ordre et les institutions dit
il les événements de timisoara sont très
graves
il faut maintenant rechercher les
auteurs de ces troubles il s'agit de
hooligans de terroristes fascistes
manipulés par des services secrets
étrangers précise monsieur schaus et
secouent la capitale budapest est
quadrillée par la police et l'armée
la plupart des grandes villes du pays en
état de siège mais la télévision
roumaine garde le silence sur ces
événements et diffuse un reportage le
voyage de ceausescu atterrant le
dictateur marxiste léniniste et at&t
s'inclinant sur la tombe du musulman
khomeiny au même moment toujours à
timisoara
de nouvelles manifestations dégénèrent
et tourne à l'affrontement
alors que l'on apprend que tous les
étudiants de la ville aurait été
déportés